welcome agent as a new member of the
shield team you've joined forces with
the world's mightiest superheroes
their methods may be a little
unconventional
the best of the best let me brief you on
the way things work around here at
shield you'll be expected to perform to
the highest of standards you'll be
required to take down Chitauri forces in
New York City defeat Dark Elves on the
plains of Sardo Heimdall and free the
world from the mechanical clutches of
evil robots
I am mighty Asgard
sokovia South Africa
these are just some of the locations
you'll be able to freely roam in these
areas you can take on special challenges
hunt down collectables and recruit new
heroes to our cause
but nothing compares to New York the
entire city is yours to explore rescue
citizens in peril
complete races keep a lid on crime
wherever it emerges evil is out there
waiting around every corner this job may
be dangerous you may be attacked by
strange creatures but the Avengers have
your back
so get out there agent and make shield
proud
you